sandy alcantara two and two five starts
so far in a respectable 345 era
he's been solid in three september
starts posting to 2-5-0-e-r-a allowed
one run on five hits over six eddie's
last start on the fifth to first for
aguilar he'll get overtaken himself and
there are two away nobody on two out for
his drubal cabrera who sends the first
one out to center brinson back near the
wall makes the catch bumps into the wall
softly
and that's it for the nationals it faces
the marlins for the second time this
season august 22nd he struck out five
allowed four runs on four and two thirds
endings no decision in that one ball in
two strikes here to dickerson
and he finds a hole on the right side so
there's a base hit for corey dickerson
to start the day
and the kick in the pitch
swing and a miss right under his bet
strikeout number 80 for the year for max
scherzer first out of the game now two
on for brian anderson
swaying and a miss on a beautiful slider
two great sliders around to change them
strikeout number two two down two one
this is a big at-bat for matt joyce
kicks and delivers and the ball is
pulled slowly to the right side charged
by the second baseman garcia and thrown
to first and he beat the play and the
marlins score run dickerson from third
and it's one to nothing marlins the
throw pulled thames off the back
couldn't get back it was toward the
middle mr rojas swung on hit of the ear
to center field stevenson going back
still back and he makes the catch two
steps from the warning track in straight
away center
fans will lead it off the left hand
hitting first baseman one and two
swung on and missed and alcantara puts
thames away and that's sandy's first
strikeout of this afternoon one down
here in the second and brock holt will
be the batter
holt swings and misses back-to-back
strikeouts for sandy two away in the
second 1-0 pitch coming in and off the
end of the bat a fly ball sending joyce
back edge of the track onto the track
makes the catch
three up three down the first six have
gone down in order with sandy alcantara
on the mound bottom third of the order
for the marlins the wide of the pitch
swinging a line drive right center field
moving back on at his holt he reaches up
but he makes the catch in deep right
pass ball up max with three today and a
one two three second
center fielder andrew stevenson
swinging a line drive left field base
hit make it three for six over toward
the line dickerson will throw it in on
the run and hold stevenson to a single
out of that number nine spot he'll
become the first net to visit first base
on oh one a conscious pitch is chopped
to third big hop for anderson he'll go
the short way to second they get the
force there on the sliding stevenson
and that's it for the nationals in the
third so another good inning for sandia
contra no runs one hit one base runner
stranded the first man is on here in the
fourth inning for the nationals trailing
one nothing sandy another one-two pitch
coming to his trouble cabrera and it's
in on the hands popped up at near second
base miguel rojas is there
and
one step to the first base side of
second mickey's got it for the first
down
pitch to thames is well hit center field
brenson going back on it's going to make
the catch though
that ball squared up but brinson was
deep to begin with didn't have any
trouble
and there are two outs now in the fourth
inning for brock holt 2-2 runner goes
from first to check swinging a ball
throw down the second base a little bit
high and out at second base juan soto
caught stealing bottom half of inning
four in game one of this double header
one nothing marlins max scherzer facing
brian anderson the third baseman 3-2
pitch
and he's got it outside corner strike
three called ring him up and anderson is
not happy about it two on and two out in
a one run game here's the one two
swinging a miss got him on the slider
for strikeout number five so it's a long
inning for max but he keeps them off the
board holt draws the walk that is the
first one issued by sandy this afternoon
sandy goes to the slider gets the
strikeout a big out number one now the
bases are loaded for trey turner here it
comes
swinging a high chopper toward the third
baseman anderson hill will make no play
in this game is tied trey turner legs
out the infield singles scoring holt the
nationals won and the marlins won the
nationals a runner in scoring position
with nobody out sandy's pitch the one
and two swung on a miss he struck him
out for the second time this afternoon
and thames is over three here's the
pitch and the ball grounded and scooped
up by miggy it's short he throws on to
first base and he got him and that's
really good work by sandy alcantara
a lead-off double by as drubal cabrera
taylor in to run for him and he's
stranded at second base here cooper to
lead it off now scherzer into the wine
and a one-two to cooper on the way
swinging a mess struck you about 96 mile
an hour heater and scherzer has his
sixth strikeout of the game the bases
are loaded with two outs marte is going
to get the at-bat
to third key boom
way back near the line and bob first
base
martay is safe
harrison scores there was a little
hesitation from kibu just a little bit
but that's all it took tying run on with
nobody out here in the top of the
seventh inning
and he'll touch one to left
ball's got some carry to it and it is at
the base of the wall
into third garcia first major league hit
yada yall hernandez
in a huge spot so the bases are loaded
kurt suzuki against brandon kinsler
struck him out kenzler got it done in a
pressure pack top of the seventh strikes
out the pinch hitter kurt suzuki